how did awkward people survive
Evolution there's this curious and
strong correlation between social
awkwardness and what researchers call
extraordinary achievement or striking
Talent people
who achieve amazing things in this world
things that are kind of at the tail end
of the bell curve uh they're actually
more likely to be awkward and the reason
for that is this obsessive interest in
things yeah they become obsessed with
the details and the minutia and then
trying to put those pieces together in
different ways that
obsessiveness then translates into
persisting through um kind of hard times
and challenges and then also eventually
getting to a point where they can
achieve something that's really pretty
exceptional that's so interesting so
when I ask why evolutionarily would
would an aid person even make it uh it's
because there are huge
advantages